[Music]  after the excitement of my 1000th  episode on tuesday tragedy struck  i woke up the next morning unable to  speak i had finally been silenced  literally  the doctor said i had laryngitis  he said it's a minor illness i should be  fine in a few days  i tried to tell him that it might not be  serious medically but it's serious to me  emotionally  but my words came out in squeaks and  grunts like a baby pig  i had never felt so marginalized  those of us in the voice depleted  community vdc face this kind of erasure  every day our trauma is real our lived  experiences are valid  we are victims too  and you can never take that away from us  i will soldier on in the face of bigotry  and ableism and my story will be an  inspiration to millions  the show will be back soon godspeed  hashtag laryngitis survivor  hashtag spg4l  [Music]